it's seven o'clock in London nine
o'clock in Kiev where a battle is
underway for control of the capital as
Russia's invasion of Ukraine enters a
third day
street fighting in Kiev and gunfire and
shelling heard in the capital here as
Russian forces close in
[Music]
in other towns and cities heavy fighting
continues between the Russian and
Ukrainian armies
shocking footage emerges of a shooting
at a hospital in the southeast of the
country the enemy will use all its
forces to break our resistance vile
cruel and inhuman the fate of Ukraine is
being decided right now every civilian
should be as careful as possible
the U.N security Council resolution
telling Moscow to stop attacking Ukraine
and pull out its troops is vetoed by
Russia
anti-war protests are held across Russia
and thousands of protesters take to the
streets in countries bordering Russia
calling for The Invasion to stop
and the Ukrainian tennis player who
wants to go back home and fight for his
country
I've actually signed up for reserves
last week and last year from Saturday I
don't have a military experience I do
have gun experience
privately
I will have the latest throughout the
morning
and we'll bring you all the newspapers
and the Press reviews with the former
Moscow correspondent for the guardian
Jonathan Steele and the writer and
broadcaster Benedict Spence
[Music]
good morning Ukrainian forces are in a
battle to hold Kiev as Russian forces
storm towards the capital here
explosions have been heard in the city
itself and heavy fighting has been
reported in the surrounding areas there
are also reports this morning of
fighting on the streets against Russian
forces with Witnesses reporting hearing
gunfire close to the government quarters
in central Kiev across the country many
cities are under attack from Russian
heavy artillery and ground forces
footage has emerged of shootings and
bombings at hospitals the Ukrainian
President says he wants a ceasefire and
peace but it seems he himself is one of
Vladimir Putin's main targets
these are the latest developments as
Russia's Invasion enters a third day
Russian troops are closing in on Kiev
with explosions and gunfire heard in the
capital overnight
Ukraine's President Vladimir zielinski
has appealed for a ceasefire and warned
that multiple cities were under attack
residents have been urged to arm
themselves to help fend off Invaders
meanwhile a U.N security Council
resolution telling Moscow to stop
attacking Ukraine and withdraw all
troops immediately was vetoed by Russia
the vote was 11-1 though with China
India and the United Arab Emirates
abstaining Dominic waghorn has this
report
kiev's maidan Square
Crucible of Ukraine's People Power
Revolution Menace through the night
by the sound of constant gunfire and
explosions
[Applause]
the fighting is coming closer and closer
to the center
foreign
this is thought to have been filmed on
one of the main routes into the city
burning vehicles on paramahi or Victory
Avenue
across the capital the sound of
explosions through the night as
Ukraine's presidents issued this Call to
Arms to his people
tonight the enemy will use all its
forces to break our resistance vile
cruel and inhuman tonight they will
storm
anyone who has already joined the
defense of the country or can help the
defense stop the enemy wherever you can
more apocalyptic scenes see the night
sky in the south of the country the city
of mikalayev lit up by a huge Fireball
Russia's invasion of Ukraine continues
relentlessly Columns of armor streaming
through its highways
and with the reports of atrocities this
is reportedly an attack on a hospital in
militar
in Kiev Ukrainian forces are deploying
as the Russians encircle their City
fighting in these residential areas
could lead to huge civilian loss of life
foreign
Exodus from the capital continues people
rushing to flee their beleaguered City
seeking safety further west
scenes Europe has a witnessed for 80
years played out as Russia's unprovoked
attack on its neighbor continues without
restraint
our diplomatic Affairs editor Dominic
waghorn joins me now from Moscow and
Dominic with all the condemnation the
economic sanctions the U.N security
Council meeting with China abstaining
President Putin is cutting an isolated
figure
yeah more and more Pariah status beckons
for Russia losing all those sporting
venues and events yesterday it also
barred from the European Eurovision song
contest ignominis of ignomanies and um I
think you know that's something that
will be weighing on the minds of
Russians but not probably Vladimir Putin
or the the elites surrounding him he
seems hell-bent on invading and
occupying and taking over Ukraine and
he's making some progress in that
respect but not the progress that you
you might think he might be expecting um
he's taken the town of militar not
without an attack on the town's Hospital
tactics that we saw Russian military
carry out in Syria with devastating
effects attacking one hospital after
another there well they seem to have
attacked a hospital in Melita pole
shelling the building and killing four
injuring 10 and the use of cluster bombs
as well according to Human Rights Watch
there they have taken that but they've
had a pretty big setback in the Downing
of another illusion 76 transport plane
they've lost two of those now and
American officials uh believe that on
board the second one were a hundred
paratroopers that's a major setback a
big significant setback for Vladimir
Putin and I think it raises the question
as to why is he uh using these higher
risk tactics why is he using
paratroopers uh when he could simply uh
roll his way into Ukraine with these
armored columns and I think it probably
could be answered by the theory that
he's probably going for a quicker
success than that kind of slower success
he'd get with the armor column progress
and advances
um he may well be going for the kind of
Blitzkrieg operation uh that analysts
have said he needs to deliver the
Russian people if he can't be quickly
successful and deliver on a swift
decisive Victory then public sentiment
in Russia is going to move away from him
so that may be why he's been using these
high-risk tactics using paratroopers and
trying to seize these airports that he
could then fly in forces in considerable
numbers to then encircle cities now um
that may be a sign of the program he's
aiming towards but he does seem to be
achieving it so far and he has been
pushed back by stiff Ukrainian
resistance now that may be leading to
frustration and Western officials in a
troubling briefing yesterday said they
were worried that he is so frustrated
his commanders are so frustrated they
may be considering more drastic Weaponry
using things like thermobaric bombs
thumb about bombs are devastating they
suck in oxygen they uh deprive anyone
around them of oxygen but they also
cause much bigger shock waves which are
devastating for people around them if he
were to use those in residential areas
it would be devastating but Western
officials say they they are worried that
he is so frustrated with the pace of his
progress he may be considering resorting
to them I have to treat that with some
skepticism of course there isn't
information war going on but that's what
western officials are telling us
okay Dominic thank you very much so
let's have a closer look now where this
battle is being fought across this
country well according to UK defense
intelligence Russian forces are coming
from two directions into uh this uh City
or the outskirts of the city in order to
surround it uh heavy fighting has been
reported at hostel Air Base to the
capitals Northwest its control has
apparently been switching back and forth
as uh fighting continues around that
Airfield looking at the country more
broadly well fighting has been reported
in many towns and cities of course
Russian troops are mostly concentrated
though in three areas this is consistent
with reports that Ukrainian forces have
said that Russian military vehicles have
crossed the border in the North near
kharkiv as well as entering from Belarus
up in the Northwest Russian Artillery
has also been coming from annexed Crimea
part of Ukraine or was and still is but
a short while ago the Ukrainian
president zelenski released a video that
suggests he is still in this city
good morning to everyone ukrainians
lately there has been a lot of fake
information online that I called on our
army to lay down arms and to evacuate
we will not lay down the weapons we will
defend our state because our weapon is
our truth and the truth is that this is
our land our country our children
and we will defend all of that
that's all that I wanted to tell you
glory to Ukraine and joining me now is
the Armed Forces Minister James hepey
good morning to you from uh Kiev and it
seems uh that the ukrainians are still
holding out still defending this city
against Putin's military they are
putting up quite a fight
they certainly are in fact we in the mod
don't recognize
um Dominic's report that melatopol has
fallen to the Russians
um as far as we're concerned all of
Russia's main day one objectives of
kharkiv kessen chenahieve Mara Paul Sumi
and melatopol are still in Ukrainian
hands and what you're seeing in Kiev at
the moment are very isolated pockets of
Russian Special Forces and paratroopers
the main armored columns approaching
Kiev are still some way off and that is
a testament to the incredible resistance
that the Ukrainian armed forces have put
up over the last 48 hours or so
yeah I mean that would seem to be right
as regards Kiev certainly the fighting
we're hearing is on the outskirts of the
city some small arms fighting uh more
centrally but
um the fear has to be given it is this
massive Russian army that a much bigger
more dangerous assault on this city is
about to occur in the coming hours and
days
well I think that's right
um clearly the Russian uh plan is to
take Keith but the reality is is that
the ukrainians are thwarting them thus
far and that is an incredible effort on
their part and that brings into play all
sorts of challenges for Russia uh they
will need to start to consider how they
will resupply the troops that have taken
longer to get down to Kiev than they
thought they will need to resupply those
who have been engaged in very Fierce
combat all around other Ukrainian cities
so there's a there's a there's a
challenge for the Kremlin that I'm not
sure that we think they necessarily
thought they would have to work their
way through and that is potentially an
opportunity for the ukrainians to
um to fight back even more we'll see
what what happens look it's a very grave
situation but from our perspective here
in the MD from what we're picking up
from the ukrainians from what we're
seeing
um through the various uh ways that we
see things uh it looks like uh the
Russian plan is nowhere near running to
schedule and I think that will be a
great cause for concern for President
Putin and rather points to the fact that
there was an awful lot of hubris in the
Russian plan and that he may well be
awfully advised
well I mean the bottom line is he has a
very powerful military and he could turn
the awesome power of that military on
this city uh anytime he wants I mean are
you still trying to get arms in to
um that help the Ukrainian forces
we are very much trying to get lethal
Aid to the ukrainians uh the UK uh
convened a donor conference yesterday
evening chaired by Ben Wallace the
Secretary of State 25 countries attended
um many of whom as a consequence of that
committed to either humanitarian or
lethal Aid which the UK will now work
with allies to make sure is delivered
um whereas a few weeks ago we were able
to be quite open about the fact that we
were delivering enlaw and we were able
to facilitate media coverage of its
arrival as you will appreciate Mark the
situation is now somewhat different and
so the detail of what we're giving and
when is probably something that we need
to keep to ourselves
um but Ukrainian calls have been heard
we've seen as you will have seen uh how
much the Ukrainian armed forces have
valued using the n-law and tank weapon
that we provide lasting round and
there's anecdotal evidence that that has
been very successful in battle
um so we know what the ukrainians want
we're doing our best to get it to them
but I'm afraid it's probably not detail
that we can share in with any sort of
candle I'm afraid
I suffice to say though are you
confident that you can get this
equipment in
yes
if the Russians do come in and topple
this government a freely elected
democratic government what would the
West do to reverse that
well I think that that is the the sort
of two parts to challenge our previous
conversation about is what do you do
immediately to try to assist in the uh
in the Ukrainian attempts to repel the
Russian Advance
um and as we've been very clear
throughout that isn't uh I think about
NATO troops playing an active role in
the conflict but is very much about
looking at how we support uh the
Ukrainian Armed Forces
the why the the longer term competition
with Russia sorry to interrupt sorry
sorry intuitive situation in which you
know Russia is controlling this country
so if you're still going to support the
Ukrainian armed forces are you saying
that you would support and recognize a
government in Exile
and you would support and arm
a resistance movement wherever that was
being located and based
well that is a decision for the National
Security Council to take but it is
something that the Prime Minister has
asked us in the ministry of Defense to
look at and plan for so that the
National Security Council has that
choice to make if and when that time
comes but I was going to go on to to
reflect that actually Putin has a
further aim Beyond territorial gain in
Ukraine which is around fracturing the
NATO alliance and pushing NATO away from
Russia's borders
there's obviously things that the
Secretary General has announced over the
last 24 hours to make sure that Putin
gets the opposite to what he wants but
then there is a 10 20-year project I
think uh where the West will be back
into quite acute competition with Russia
where imposing cost on Putin the
kleptocrats that surround him so that he
fails and he is seen to fail and he has
no opportunity to anoint his successor
and Russia fundamentally changes as a
country as a consequence because the
Russian people just have had enough of
him that is something where I think the
UK and our allies have got time to make
good strategic decisions rather than
necessarily needing to kind of rush
there's the urgency of supporting the
ukrainians in what they're doing right
now and then there's making good
strategic decisions around how we make
sure that Putin really does fail as a
consequence of the hubris he's shown
over the last week or two but just
okay but just finally it is highly
likely it sounds or is what you're
saying that you would recognize a
government in Exile and help arm a
resistance uh military a resistance Army
no you're you're putting words in my
mouth muck and I need to be very clear
as a Ministry of Defense Minister I am
be a decision for the secure National
Security exactly exactly so it's a
Ministry of Defense Minister I am
telling you that the Prime Minister has
asked to be able to have that choice at
his disposal and that is work that the
ministry of defense is uh undertaking to
look at how we would do that but it is
definitely not for me to give you any
level of probability that is a decision
rightly that sits with the Prime
Minister and the National Security
Council
okay uh James heapey appreciate your
time uh this morning on what uh could be
a very difficult day for this country
thank you thank you
right uh Deborah Haynes uh security and
defense editor is with me so well
there's a lot to go at there's still
want to get arms in for the military
here now and if the government is
toppled they are going to consider
clearly uh arming some sort of
resistance operation and and you know
backing a government in Exile yes it's
the one thing isn't it that we keep
hearing from the Ukrainian side is that
they say they've got the Manpower
they've got the will to fight but they
need weapons and so really interesting
that Ben Wallace the UK defense
secretary held this virtual donor
conference yesterday evening to get
support and also I understand that some
of the countries on that call were those
that had actually previously been
against supplying lethal Aid to Ukraine
um but that actually they've now changed
their mind since President Putin invaded
its neighbor and in terms of the actual
Aid that we're talking about it's things
like ammunition anti-tank missiles
anti-air weapons and then things like
medical supplies as well much needed
medical supplies the question is though
whether it's going to be enough and like
you said things are looking pretty
dangerous today we've heard explosions
through the night gunfire here in the
capital so you do really wonder how this
day will end although it wasn't as as
um as I don't think we I mean you're
right it is then we there is fighting
outside but the a major assault on this
capital city has not happened yet
exactly and
take away from what the Armed Forces
Minister was saying he clearly people
believe that the Russian objectives are
not going to time the timetable that
they've planned he listed a load of
cities that he said Russia had intended
to take on the first day and as of now
Western officials say they don't believe
that Russia has control of any of the
main cities so that is a significant
setback if that really was the schedule
that Vladimir Putin was working to but
as we were told by Western officials
yesterday they believe that as that
timetable is impacted by the Ukrainian
military's ability to to defend their
country then the tempo of the Firepower
being launched against them and the
potential indiscrimination of the
weapons used could rise exactly and
missiles are hitting areas on the
outskirts of this Capital they're
hitting buildings and people are dying
well yeah exactly I mean I went and
visited an apartment block yesterday
where there'd been some sort of missile
strike right outside totally destroyed
like a whole wall of 10-story apartment
blocks lives completely ruined and it
totally totally lays to it just exposes
the fallacy of the entire narrative that
President Putin has built to justify
this Invasion that he's somehow coming
in to help save this country we're
actually the opposite is true he's
coming in trying to enforce himself on
this country which had under under the
government been trying to to build
closer ties to the West which is
something that is seen in Moscow as an
existential threat yeah absolutely
Deborah thank you very much for the
moment well turning now to other parts
of the country and in dinitro uh down in
Southeastern Ukraine where the Ukrainian
government has said Russian airstrikes
have been targeting a lot of military uh
sites there military facilities we can
join Skies John Sparks who is there on
the ground for us and John donipro not a
city that's talked about in this a lot
but strategically quite important
yeah that's right good morning Mark
that's right a major transport Hub it
sort of stands in the in the center of
the country in the Eastern section A
logistically important important terms
of Transport for troops and supplies and
Logistics
um it's quiet here at the moment it's an
eerily quiet very few people on the
streets but we know that in a city
located very close to nepro called
poltava it has been hit by the Russian
version of the cruise missile fired from
the Black Sea along with a number of
other cities Sumi and Maria Paul
assuming the Northeast maripole in the
Southeast
so it is a target the outskirts of this
city will certainly remain a Target and
I think you know I think the focus of
the Russian forces at the moment clearly
is on the capital the capital is is
essentially Under Siege uh gunfire being
reported in main sections of the city
City Central train station Maiden square
and we have heard from City officials in
Kiev telling people to watch out because
street fighting has started to take
place in sections of the city people are
being told to take shelter immediately
to stay away from Windows and balconies
to avoid flying debris and bullets gives
you an idea of just how dangerous the
situation here there is as well the US
has reportedly offered to evacuate
president zelenski although he he hasn't
taken them up on the offer and there was
a video that he released on Twitter I
mean zielinski very quickly becoming a
global hero now he released a short
video saying don't believe the fake news
I'm still here still calling on
ukrainians to fight
U.S intelligence also warning however
the ukrainians that they believe the
Russians have inserted hit squads into
the capital to take zelinski out and I
think there are there's every indication
that that is true President Putin quoted
last night describing the Ukrainian
government as a bunch of drug addicts
and neo-nazis of course with all the
fighting there is still a refugee crisis
now well underway the un's refugee
agency the unhcr say 50 000 people are
on the Move have left their homes in the
last 48 hours many going south to
Moldova many more going west to Poland
and also to Romania as well the Polish
president has said he will accept every
Ukrainian Refugee who comes to the
border and we're hearing that the cues
at the border are 10 hours long or more
also the Romanians saying they have room
for half a million refugees from Ukraine
acts of extraordinary generosity because
that's what it is at a really dark time
for Ukraine
John thank you very much let's just
bring you some pictures that we're
getting in
um these are live pictures in Kiev on
the outskirts of Kiev and what you can
see there is a clearly damaged building
thought to be a residential building and
that is on the outskirts of Kiev close
to the airport we're told
um and it's we don't know exactly
um what happened but that uh that
residential block has clearly come under
attack and that is on the outskirts of
Kiev they are live pictures this morning
well in the South Russian attacks have
spread along Ukraine's Coastline amid
suggestions that a new assault could
soon be underway there Alex Rossi
reports now from Mario poll on the
attack from the south
it has been an horrific 24 hours
the hospital directors take me to see
soldiers injured on the Eastern Front
will see staff Lieutenant Andre was
lacerated with shrapnel he's heavily
medicated but says as soon as he's
recovered he wants to fight again
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
has just come out of surgery he's in
pain
Dr Alexi says he expects to see many
more blast injuries in the days to come
over
which
is
foreign
but it's unlikely any help will arrive
Mario Paul like the rest of the country
is besieged and on its own
the people here are exhausted they stay
inside unless they need supplies but
after years of fighting they're inured
to the sound of War most don't even
Flinch when the shells start flying
we're on the outskirts of Mario Paul in
the eastern district
the front lines are over in that
direction we've been listening to the
sound of a very heavy artillery battle
it's hard to say exactly how far it is
away but it sounds as though Russian
forces are getting now much closer to
the city
and a sphere hovers over this place a
steady stream of evacuees are getting
out whilst they can
this man's putting his wife and daughter
on the train to safety before he goes
back in the army
[Music]
foreign
many families will be separated in the
days to come and with the Russian
invasion battering every corner of this
country there's no doubt there will be
many more tears Alex Rossi Sky News
Mario Paul
well a resolution condemning moscow's
invasion of Ukraine was vetoed at the
United Nations security Council
predictably by Russia but China failed
to back Vladimir Putin's actions and
sanctions against the Russian leader are
growing here's our U.S correspondent
Mark Stone
Battalion along Europe's Eastern flank
the latest deployment of soldiers more
Americans part of a now growing NATO
Defense Force the order and the ceremony
in such contrast to an upending of World
Order which feels at least so real
and at the world's top diplomatic Forum
an evening vote on a resolution
condemning Russia those against
which didn't pass but did provide what's
being seen as a significant moment
abstentions China considered by Russia
to be a friend did not vote with them
against the resolution
Beijing could not condone what's
happening in Ukraine
Western diplomats finding success within
a failed vote they peeled apart two
allies getting a Chinese abstention
adding to Putin's isolation the
resolution was supported by all member
states of the European Union
and many partners from around the world
together with Ukraine we will now work
for the general assembly to demand an
immediate withdrawal of Russia Russian
forces from Ukraine
hi everyone at the White House the
decision to match what the EU and UK had
already done to take sanctions further
to hit President Putin himself the
president is doing nearly everything in
his power to lead the world and stand up
against the actions of President Putin
what he will not do is send U.S troops
to fight in Ukraine because he is not
going to put the American public the
American people or the United States in
a position of fighting a war with Russia
and that's the nub of it that's why NATO
forces will not roll into Ukraine to end
all this it is about sanctions now
against Putin himself freezing his
assets potentially Banning him from
traveling tactics that were once a
deterrent now feel so reactionary and
against a man who isn't listening are
you worried for president zielinsky of
course he's worried but the past few
days has revealed the blunt and
troubling reality what can be done
without Unthinkable escalation
Mark Stone Sky News at the White House
well protests against the Ukrainian
Invasion are growing in Russia and its
uh surrounding countries thousands of
protesters took to the streets in the
Georgian Capital calling for an end to
the invasion huge crowds gathered
outside the parliament buildings there
they called for the resignation of uh
Georgia's prime minister who said his
country would not join the West in
sanctioning Russia
anti-war demonstrations have taken place
at more than 50 Russian cities police
made a number of arrests in some
peterborgs and some peterberg where
those involved in um a peaceful protest
were grabbed by Riot police and then
arrested that is a Putin's home City
in Moscow people came from across the
city to Mark another night of uh bombing
here they laid flowers and lit candles
at the Ukrainian Embassy
and in London more than a thousand
people rallied outside Downing Street
chanting Russia go home many were from
Ukraine and were well clearly upset
about the events going on in their
country
a little earlier Ukrainian president uh
zielinski released this video
good morning to everyone ukrainians
lately there has been a lot of fake
information online that I called on our
army to lay down arms and to evacuate
we will not lay down the weapons we will
defend our state because our weapon is
our truth and the truth is that this is
our land our country our children
and we will defend all of that
that's all that I wanted to tell you
glory to Ukraine
and that video in fact was recorded this
morning so president zielinski clearly
still in this city
well the invasion of Ukraine has drawn a
sharp reaction from sporting bodies many
of which have been quick to distance
themselves from Russia I'm joined now by
the chief football writer at the Times
Martin Ziegler thank you very much
indeed for being with us Martin so
football it seems is moving against
Putin
uh yes good morning Mark it's uh I mean
unprecedented times and unprecedented
response from sport including football
uh UEFA have
um moved to strip some Petersburg of the
Champions League final in May they've
moved back to Paris they're going to
terminate a massive 80 million pound
sponsorship deal with gas prom and uh in
major racing with the Formula One is
being removed from Sochi in September so
yes I think almost United response from
sport
but gas prom does remain at the moment
at least the sort of major sponsor of
the Champions League
yeah I my understanding is that um the
uefa's lawyers are working on this and I
think it's very unlikely we'll see any
gas prom advertising when the next round
of matches take place
it's interesting isn't it I mean do you
think a lot of this stuff will be kind
of temporary you know take action make a
headline and then you know money will
talk in six months a year or two years
or so
I mean I think you know it's going to
very much depend on what happens I mean
we have seen sort of the sporting World
bending over to Russia over the over the
last 10 years if if not longer
um and the international Olympic
Committee FIFA have all been very very
supportive above the regime but I I
think I mean the the sense I get is that
um there's been such shock amongst
sporting circles that even those figures
who are very keen on being pictured with
Vladimir Putin in the in the past have
um realized actually things have got to
change
so where does all this leave do you
think people like uh Abramovich at
Chelsea a man who's poured money into
Chelsea where do you think there'll be
some action down the line against uh
people like that
well there's certainly lots of concern
amongst abramovich's
um people that he is going to be on the
on the next list to be targeted I mean
there was an expectation
um because there were calls in the House
of Commons that that the government
should step in and take action against
him and he even removed Chelsea from his
ownership
um he's put 1.5 billion pounds into the
club and as things stand he can still he
can still keep going it's he now has
Portuguese and Israeli citizenship so
whether that's a factor two it's quite
difficult to know but there's certainly
concern around the club and his um
Entourage
and just finally are you hearing any
other moves that maybe announced uh in
sport uh relating to what is happening
here in Ukraine
well the fact the international Olympic
Committee has called for all
International sporting federations to
remove events from Russia I think is I
mean I was amazed that they went that
far but they have done um so there are
some for example International Swimming
Federation has not gone down that far
volleyball has said they're still
pressing ahead with the World
Championships from the Russia in the
summer but I think the pressure on those
Sports will become too intense for them
to cut to continue
okay Martin thanks very much for uh
being with us this morning appreciate
your time thank you
well our Sports presenter Jackie beltrow
joins me now from Sky News Center good
morning Jackie it does seem on the face
of it at least that sport is doing its
bit
yes there's one paper said yesterday
finding its moral compass Mark
um I've been chatting to a former
Ukrainian tennis player Serge takovsky
who retired uh just last month actually
and he's been on a family holiday trying
to get back to Kiev and he thinks that
sporting sanctions will really hurt
Putin because he's all about the glory
and the flag and the national anthems
and showing just how great his country
is through sport sporting sanctions will
really really hurt him but he said for
the minute it's not about sport it's
about fighting he has put down his
racket he is trying to get back to Kiev
because he wants to pick up a gun
I've actually signed up for reserves uh
last week and last year from Saturday it
makes a world of difference to our
arms forces I would say
ing that they're not left alone at least
[Music]
in the media environment but might be
realistic yeah it's been 80 years of the
war since Russia whether it was a Russia
proxies or Russia itself it doesn't
matter where was all of this for these
years
other players have been speaking out as
well and the top 10 player Elena
svitolina now Alina monfis has been
incredibly stressed in that interview
with starkovsky he broke down at least
twice he's so worried about his family
in Kiev and it's a very similar story
for Ukrainian sports stars who are far
away from their country right now
for me I almost didn't sleep for this 28
hours uh I cannot even imagine uh what
people going through uh when they they
closed their eyes and they hear uh bombs
when they hear uh shooting outside their
house so for sure you you you care you
are really nervous and really think
thinking about your family so for me
it's a completely uh normal that some
people and some some Sportsmen taking
time off uh me I'm I'm extremely nervous
as well
yeah they're all the sports stars
incredibly stressed about what's going
on back home we've got Jan malenko who
plays for West Ham he's asked for a few
days off he's not going to be playing in
their match against wolves this weekend
because you know honestly how can you
think about playing football or playing
tennis or whatever it is when such a
thing is going back uh going on in back
in your home country and the the level
of stress coming through in these
interviews
um is incredible
okay Jackie thank you very much indeed
and uh we were just showing you pictures
a few moments ago of a residential block
here on the outskirts of uh this city
and we're just getting some information
about what happened there those are the
pictures and uh clearly
um severe damage to that residential
block well the Ukrainian authorities are
now saying that that was caused by a
missile strike from Russia but they also
say
um and it seems quite extraordinary
looking at what we are seeing there that
there were no casualties so
in the midst of all this uh ghastly
stuff going on no casualties is is some
relief that strike happening overnight
and that is a residential block over
near uh the airport so um the Russians
May well have been attacking that
airport as they have been in the in the
last few days
well Ukraine's Minister Ministry of
Defense has been urging citizens to arm
themselves in order to fight off the
invading forces one of those who's taken
up the call is the leader of the golos
zamin political party Kira rudick who
posted this picture to social media
saying that she had taught herself to
use a Kalashnikov and Was preparing to
bear arms and she joins me now from here
in Kiev thank you Kira for being with us
this morning and what is your
understanding I mean it seems quite calm
clearly in the center but what is your
understanding of what is going on in
this city at the moment
so I live in solomonska District
the shooting that hit the
tall story building is here like five
minute uh walk and the night was really
tough you probably seen it yourself uh
we had at least three Sirens during the
night three times when everybody had to
go to the bomb shelters and there were
air strikes uh on Kiev there were also
about 60 people killed from the Russian
side and they will go back to where they
came from in plastic bags I think Putin
right now understood how he
underestimated Ukraine and ukrainians in
their ability to fight back so we have
our army who is strategically kicking
Putin's um back and we have our
resistance forces which I am a part of
right now
um who are
fixing what went through their cracks uh
through our through our army and I think
we are doing very well we are very
successful in it and every morning we
are waking up to a better hope and we
every morning we are waking up to a
better understanding of that we actually
will win
how long do you think you can hold out
how long can the Ukrainian forces do you
think hold out against what is
clearly uh a very powerful Army
so first of all we are not alone so we
are getting support from countries all
over the world and getting more and more
uh weapons and financial support so I
think we still have uh a week or so to
stand and fight for ourselves plus the
uh I'm very sure that we will be
fighting back and pushing them backwards
and up to our borders uh these couple of
days uh I think starting yesterday are
really really hard that's true but it's
also
um it's also creating this force that is
fighting Russians back from our side the
resistance force that is prevailing
right now that it's stopping uh all the
attempts to take the city and that is
regrouping right now to fight back and
kick them away
but Kira I mean the reality is that a
much bigger Onslaught assault on this
city uh may come in the coming hours and
days and um then things could be very
different uh after if that did happen
would you stay in the city
I am Ukrainian MP and the leader of a
political party my duty is to stay with
my people and I will do so my duties to
protect my country and I will do so and
or as a citizen I am a very very angry
for that I I could even imagine going
from where I live somewhere else just
because Putin decided that he wants to
deny Ukraine and ukrainians the right
for existing
and just finally do you think we've seen
president zielinski make a statement
this morning it seems clear he is still
here do you think he will also stay or
do you think he would go and maybe set
up some sort of government in Exile
uh
no like this these last two days are the
times where I'm an opposition political
a politician is I'm very proud of the
president's zelenski so I wish him
strengths and he has all our support
because we are all fighting for each
other and uh I hope that he wouldn't
flee we are all here and this is our
land this is our soil and we just have
no right to take a step back
all right Kira it's very good to talk to
you and maybe we'll check in with you uh
tomorrow and see how things are going
but thank you for being with us
Kyra rudick there a politician here in
uh Kiev and I've got to say a lot of the
politicians a lot of MPS are not only
staying but we interviewed one Neil
um uh in Kiev he was walking through
Kiev and he had the AK-47 with him
strapped across his shoulder and said he
would fight and a lot of the MPS are
staying and saying that they will fight
so that is the picture here but as I say
the you know a really big assault that
was predicted last night a massive
assault on this there have been attacks
uh make no mistake but the big assault
on this city has not happened as yet and
mercifully of course it won't Neil back
to you to have a look at the papers okay
Mark thanks very much and as Mark was
saying that I think we are all getting
an insight into the character of your
average Ukrainian and might something we
might discuss indeed with our guest this
morning to take us through the papers
the former Moscow correspondent for the
guardian John Steele and the writer and
broadcaster Benedict Spence James good
to see you again um Jonathan let's come
to you first this time uh we're looking
at the guardian and they're reporting on
that Exodus as they describe it to the
Western borders
there's still got a very graphic picture
of a terrified woman with her small son
at Kiev Central Station desperately
trying to find a place on a train going
to Western Ukraine it's just one of many
images we've seen of people fleeing the
city on foot even on in cars massive car
uh Exodus and uh
traffic jams of course because by that
and then people piling into trains as
well and to get to the western part of
the country and then go across the
border into Poland Romania Moldova which
have all said that they will welcome and
help and shelter as many refugees as
come so there's there's no problem of
getting a shell to one you get there you
will be welcomed but obviously there's
going to be a massive logistical issue
of finding places for people to stay the
UN High commission for refugees is
stepping in and they're getting
tents and other facilities available for
people
um Benedict of course uh plenty of
ukrainians particularly men of fighting
age you know 18 plus I have stayed to
defend the country we've been seeing
president zielinski a man clearly
possesses some pretty big kahunas but I
mean your average Ukrainian citizen
picking up a gun many of them without
any military experience you've got to
say the same about them as well
I think so um it's in many ways you know
one doesn't want to you know think of
people staying behind to fight and
potentially die but it is you know as we
said in the last segment president
zielinski has sort of led by example uh
he was very calm in the build up to all
of this you know sort of downplaying
Western fears that an invasion was
likely you know to keep people calm to
say to people stay at home and that does
mean that there are quite a lot of
people who are able to pick up uh
weapons and potentially defend their
their country it's not what you want to
see but I do think it's actually what
you would expect a lot of people to do
uh in such a situation
um and you know the the the flip side of
this is of course you do see lots of
countries Poland and Slovakia you know
most notably have thrown open their
borders uh Mazzio salvini the Italian uh
right-wing politician who is formerly a
very big fan of Putin has said it is
Italy's duty to take in ukrainians uh
wherever they appear the major issue now
appears to be sort of countries further
west like the UK potentially like France
and Germany who are not necessarily
being as well occurring just yet
um so you know it remains to be seen
whether or not that would be the case
obviously it's slightly more pressing
for countries like Slovakia and Poland
that do share a border uh to get those
people over
um but you know that's the situation
that we find ourselves in right now uh
Ukraine does have an awful lot of people
who are prepared to stay and fight and
that is its best bet right now that's
its only hope uh it's certainly as NATO
isn't prepared to commit troops to
defend them Jonathan take us to the
Telegraph and what they're describing
are incredibly accurately of course as
as the the battle for Kiev and it
certainly feels that there is an awful
lot of significance being attached on
the Ukrainian side to being able to
repel the Russians and of course on the
Russian side to continue the advance and
perhaps even to take the city
well obviously the Kiev is the main goal
of President Putin to try and get in
there and then set up some kind of
alternative government which will
obviously be considered by most
ukrainians as a puppet and a disgrace
and treachery and the quizlings and all
the rest of it but there is I think a
big danger which is that if the
Ukrainian resistance continues to be as
strong as it apparently is button may
start using our power in a traumatic way
and we'll see scenes like we've seen
across near the capital of chechnya
which Putin attacked in the 1990s and
2000 and uh or the cities in Syria which
had been completely destroyed buildings
are completely smashed and population
totally evacuated and fleeing so there's
a difficult balance here between the
resistance that has a chance of winning
and resistance are just delays the
inevitable but increases the the
Firepower of the Russians to use APPA
and and really smash the city and
disregard any issue of Civilian
casualties
yeah and Benedict I mean certainly we
were listening to Mark Austin speaking
to the defense minister James CP a
little bit earlier on today they are
they are certainly planning uh looking
at planning the contingency planning for
for arming assisting you know whatever
kind of resistance movement steps up but
we shouldn't forget I mean the biggest
what perhaps the biggest
tool that we have at our disposal
remains sanctions and and one suspects
that there will be even more of those
yeah it's difficult because there's been
a lot of you know sort of hue and cry
about some countries not putting in
enough you know not doing enough to
impose sanctions I mean you've got the
slightly farcical and outrageous
situation of Belgium asking for
exemptions on diamond sales to Russians
and Italy for luxury goods you know
clearly Prada and you know diamonds are
very important uh to people right now
yeah but if you want to park those
um and look at you know slightly more
serious things it is a difficult
Balancing Act simply because Russia has
sort of embedded itself so firmly in key
aspects of the global economy we talk a
lot about fuel in the west but actually
you know the key thing I think to look
at is human fuel it's food it's
agricultural fertilizers it's weeds
um you know it were sanctions to be
stepped up too massively you could see
these things being reduced uh in their
supplies to Western countries to Eastern
countries to countries in Africa and the
problem is there you know we saw Imran
Khan he was in Moscow yesterday sort of
kissing the muscovite ring and you're
thinking what a bizarre time to be doing
that but that is of course because
Pakistan in terms of its food supply is
rather precarious and we do need to
remember that even in this country
people are only ever a couple of
paychecks away from food poverty that is
the sort of thing that leads to regime
change that's something sadly that
Ukraine knows all too well about and
that's the thing right now as much as
you want to put sanctions in place you
don't want to ramp them up so quickly to
cause a response that then leads to a
massive draining of support for any
action against Russia in Western
countries and elsewhere because that's a
Surefire thing to make sure that Ukraine
Falls and that there will be nobody
offering even military assistance in the
performance of goods and Aid